just laid on the line for us why the
prime minister should stay then after
the resignation of the chancellor and
the health secretary i can't do better
than beth rigby who said it out
perfectly that the prime minister won a
large mandate in general election of
both of the british people
and that should not be taken away from
him because a number of people resign or
um sir roger gale doesn't like it so
roger gail has never been a fan
of the prime minister as um beth rigby
quite rightly said
and
shows what a broad church the
conservative party is that it contains
people like sir roger in it and people
i mean you're more of the rights
as we know because of the the vote of
confidence we know that uh roger gayle
was hardly an outlier 40 percent of the
the party expressed a view on that a
similar view to sir roger now two
cabinet ministers including the
chancellor of the exchequer have well
the prime minister won the vote and the
thing about democracy is that if you win
the vote you've won and that i think is
is fundamental
uh yes
harold mcmillan lost his whole treasury
team and then went off for a tour of the
commonwealth saying uh he was going to
get beyond these little local
difficulties and i think it's much the
same now
that chancellors do resign and this
doesn't necessarily have any effect on
the government um mcmillan went on to be
in office for some years the same
happened to lord salisbury when randolph
churchill winston's father uh resigned
um thinking that he would force
salisbury to do what he wanted salisbury
went on to be a prime minister of years
and years afterwards so losing
chancellors is something that happens
okay but so if there were other members
and they may well be other members of
that cabinet you cheat by john with
around the table we saw you all sitting
there today if others are harboring
thoughts along the same lines as the
former chancellor and the former health
secretary i mean if they did go you'd
say the prime minister can just carry on
i think you have a wonderfully and i
rather like this 18th century view of
cabinet government that you're
absolutely right in the 18th century if
a lot of cabinet ministers went then it
meant that the king needed to send for
somebody else to be prime minister but
we've moved on from the 18th century
even i have to admit that and that the
prime minister with a mandate from the
rich people and a majority in the house
of commons is the one who appoints
cabinet ministers not somebody who is
brought down by cabinet ministers but
this isn't a presidency you know he
relies upon the collective support of
the cabinet as well and he appears to be
losing it well he relies on being able
to command a majority in the house of
commons that's different it's not a
majority of the cabinet there's no
constitutional convention of that kind
there is a constitutional convention of
the strongest kind that the prime
minister must command a majority in the
house of commons which he does and this
is very important because theresa may
didn't and that's the difference between
the situation now and then
and we got through
the controversial northern ireland
protocol bill second reading just over a
week ago with a significant majority
the prime minister's winning votes in
the house of commons and that is
fundamental okay well that's the broad
view and the background in some of the
the constitutional issues what about the
prime minister's integrity what about
what has been happening to cabinet
ministers over the last four or five
days have been sent out to say things on
behalf of the prime minister having been
briefed by downing street and it turns
out they were untrue they were misled
well there was a minor mistake that was
made it's not a minor it is it is a
minor mistake that
um in politics and indeed in journalism
and probably in every professional life
there are rumors that swirl around and
some of them are false and some of them
turn out to be true
but a prime minister cannot possibly
govern an appoint on the basis of rumor
that simply wouldn't be just and so
something may have happened in the
foreign office and well i mean
i mean you know i've got to pick you up
on rumor it was a formal complaint which
was formally investigated and by the
fire office and
donald then said it was then said that
an apology was issued and that the prime
minister was personally briefed about it
it was that he then forgot it was
something that was um investigated and
led to an apology which closed the
matter
and the prime minister you left out the
bit the prime minister was involved i
was kind of that patient's old being
patients um if the prime minister is
hearing endless things about all sorts
of public business he cannot possibly be
expected to remember
every single last detail and that this
was settled with an apology
now we don't know how serious it was
because we haven't got the details but
that something that is settled with an
apology doesn't sound like a grade one
issue
and therefore it's quite understandable
that that's not something that's at the
forefront of science but you heard the
prime minister's statement at six
o'clock this evening uh when he said
again with the benefit of hindsight he
was wrong
to appoint him yeah
but done he wouldn't have done it no if
he'd remember if he'd met if he'd
remembered that he had been briefed
about um mr pinches actually cannot show
you a big man who's willing to apologize
when he makes a mistake i'm not
pretending the prime minister didn't
make a mistake
it's obvious
that but this is a difficulty for all
leaders you know as well as i do that
there are rumors about many politicians
of all parties
and that if you take the case
of neil parrish
i was told authoritatively of two other
people who it was meant to have been
and those two people were completely
honest they had not done anything of the
kind
and yet if we were to run government if
we would run society on the basis of
rumor they would have had their name
solid as well and that can't possibly be
right so the prime minister
forgetting one incident was not swayed
by rumor and actually i think that's
right
it's the is the prime minister just
misreading your picture but it's the
prime minister
to sum this up for me is the prime
minister in your view a man of integrity
and probity yes
yes i just i just wanted to as as you're
talking lots of things are developing
um what's beginning to happen is that a
number of mps or people with junior
roles within government are now publicly
saying that they can no longer support
the prime minister sally ann hart has
just said considering further revelation
she's the mp for hastings uh i i am no
longer able to support boris johnson's
leader of the conservative party and
prime minister
bim afalami has just resigned i think he
maybe perhaps was a a vice chair
andrew morrison has also resigned as a
trade envoy i put it to you jacob
rees-mogg that whatever the prime
minister might want to do
and however many supporters he might
have in the party he's done he has lost
the back benches yes he has a big
majority
but he is going to face another
confidence vote and however much she
wants to hold on he's going to get
pushed out well
he won the confidence vote
and if there is another vote we'll see
what happens he might very well win
another if another one comes this is
getting dire for it it's like
not universal
he can just sail on constitutionally he
can carry on unless and until he loses a
vote in the house of commons then of
course the prime minister's position
would be untenable and he would have
either to resign or to call an election
that's the constitutional position and
the fixed term parliament act has been
repealed um but the three people you
mentioned i have no idea how they voted
in a secret vote in the um confidence
vote a couple weeks ago they may have
all voted against the prime minister for
all we know and even if they tweeted
their support that doesn't necessarily
mean and on that issue
just on that issue of another confidence
vote taking place in under a year the
1922 committee would have to change the
rules would you say that would be moving
the goal post that really they should
wait for a year i think in a democracy
you need to stick to the rules that you
have set at the outset i think there is
quite a widespread feeling that changing
the rules would be undesirable because
then it would be open season on any and
all leaders if you could have a
confidence vote week in week out whoever
were leader of the tory party at any
time in its future history would
constantly face this risk and i wonder
whether that's wise and i wonder whether
people on mature reflection think that
is a good thing to do but it but it
might be that that some people that hold
that view like david davis actually said
exactly that to me a few weeks ago he
wanted the prime minister to resign and
and made that argument but there will be
some mps looking at this now thinking
whether boris johnson wants to carry on
or not his government
is in deep crisis he's just lost his
chancellor in the middle of a cost of
living crisis and as a government you're
not getting on with the business of
running the country and the public are
going to lose faith
in the party
you can see that mps would be worried
and you surely are worried about whether
boris johnson can hold on even if you
would like him actually i think you make
a really important point that losing the
chance in current circumstances is
significant and if you read the
chancellor's letter that explains why
because he had fundamental differences
with the prime minister now i think that
wasn't helpful
i think the tax rises uh that we have
had have been a matter that have not
been
commanding universal support there was a
reported story that the prime minister
wanted to cut corporation tax next year
and that the chancellor was blocking it
so i think
a government works best when it has a
chancellor prime minister who are hand
in glove and i do agree with you that
that was appearing to be fraying at the
edges of a hand in the glass would you i
mean jacob rees-mogg you'd like to see
those tax cuts or those tax rises
delayed
surely i mean that's that that's what
you've been talking about all your life
in politics you pose a fascinating
question of collective responsibility
whilst there is a vacancy for the
chancellorship am i allowed to express
my own views on taxation but i think
what you've said is um a a very well put
and thoughtful view
do you think that boris johnson will be
prime minister by the end of the year oh
i'm going for walpole woolpole did 21
years but nick and i would like to are
you as confident
okay let me put another are you as
confident tonight as you were 24 hours
ago that boris johnson will remain prime
minister
um
we'll have to see if he can win
elections but so far he's been involved
we've lost two by-elections oh but
by-elections are very different from
general elections as you know
i just want to challenge you you're an
mp so
i am very confident that the prime
minister let's just ask about the
possibility of another by-election what
about chris pincher should he resign as
an mp
um
if the
allegations that have been made turn out
to be true
i think guess he should
and therefore there would be another
by-election look we have to maintain
propriety in the british political
system and if these allegations which
seem to be sexual assault
are upheld
then there is no place in the palace of
westminster for people found guilty of
sexual assault uh as you know i used to
be leader of the house and we set up the
icgs there is a good complaint service
to help
victims of these assaults and the
um
conclusions of the icgs are
fundamentally important
we have to allow mr pincher a fair
hearing we must assume innocence until
guilt has proved that justice applies
to politicians as well as to everybody
else and this is constitutionally
important but if
and it is obviously if
these facts
turn out to be the case then yes of
course and on the issue of on the issue
of elections you mentioned that jacob
ismog that you know the fixed term
parliament act has been repealed
if the prime minister demonstrably has
lost the confidence of his party he has
an option then does he not of checking
out whether the british public still
want him to remain by calling a general
election by convention if he lost a vote
of confidence in the house of commons
and that's in the whole house not just
amongst mps and the convention that
applied before the fixed term parliament
act that i assume is now reinstated then
yes there would be a general election
that's what happened when um jim
callahan lost a vote of confidence in
1979. and would you like to fight a
general election if and when it comes
with boris johnson as the leader oh
there's no other leader i would want to
fight a general election under boris
johnson
is an amazing election winner jacob just
to follow up on that you touched on this
um a while back around the confidence
that we did an interview are you saying
that you would rather
boris johnson called a general election
to test his mandate with the public than
let the parliamentary party vote him out
no that's not what i said i said the
constitutional convention is that a
prime minister who lost a vote of
confidence would go to an election on
the floor of the house on the floor of
the house um that if he lost a vote of
confidence
amongst tory mps then you would follow
the convention i assume that margaret
thatcher followed and resigned as
leaders mike i i think it would only be
in the circumstance of losing the
support of the house what i mean is
would he precipitate a general election
to put his mandate to the public before
his party try now i i have absolutely no
idea that's one of those decisions that
only the prime minister made well have
you had a conversation with me yet this
year
and what was his mood oh business as
usual he's got a job to do
very very milanesque in my view okay
unflappable calmly getting on with the
important work he's got so reshuffle
this week you can't go on without a
chancellor can you well it's only the
second order of the treasury we have a
first lord
both jobs uh we are out of time jacob
reese marco very good to see you thank
you very much indeed the brexit
opportunities minister jacob rees-mogg